The day that everyone warned about
begins with
terrifying news:
China invades Taiwan. Experts have
already mapped out
this war scenario.
They predict an
invasion by China.
Bombings that destroy Taiwan's navy and
air force.
Tens of thousands of Chinese soldiers
crossing the Taiwan Strait.
China has been threatening has
annexation for a long time.
Don't pretend that Taiwan
is not part of China.
I think we can see very clearly that
states are joining forces to redraw
the world map.
It would be a war that seems far away.
But it would have catastrophic
consequences for Germany.
We are vulnerable to blackmail, yes.
We would have supply shortages and we
would have mass unemployment.
The loss of markets would severely affect
both economies.
Hardly any other country has made itself so
dependent on China.
This is the moment when, from a
German perspective,
we need to pause and say,
Do we really still want it like this?
Because we are vulnerable.
How did it get this far?
We are looking for causes and answers.
In China, in Germany and in Taiwan.
Is there a way out of this dependency?
There are many warnings
that something is going wrong..
That the dependence on China
is becoming dangerous for us in Germany..
One warning is the story of
six-year-old Anton from Berlin.
And of his doctor Malik Böttcher, who
has known Anton for a long time.
He was someone,
who never really got sick..
And when he had a cold and a fever,
he still went to
play in the playground..
In early May,
Anton gets a serious infection..
A television crew is filming in the
doctor's practice, documenting Anton's visit to the doctor..
We examined him and saw
that he had bronchitis on the verge
to pneumonia.
And then we decided
to start antibiotic therapy.
And these antibiotics were
available in the pharmacy..
But in too small a quantity, in too low a dose.
.
It does not take much to mark the difference
between life or death..
It can be a small tablet..
If it is there,
you don't think about it..
If it is missing or, as in Anton's case, there's not enough available,
it becomes dangerous..
The reason for the shortage.
China is not supplying enough
cephalosporins, i.e. antibiotics, at this time..
And you can't do without China..
So if the Chinese stop sending us pharmaceuticals
then we will be short of cephalosporins..
And especially for severe infections
cephalosporins are very, very important..
That means, people
will die?
Yes
There is no one to tell you
not to worry,.
antibiotics will soon be available again..
The shortage becomes the new normal then?.
In Anton's case, Böttcher tries to avoid
the dependency on China by treating him
with a
lower dose.
But that doesn't work..
Shortly after these pictures were shot,
Anton is admitted to hospital
with severe pneumonia.
Being dependent on China has
hardly worried anyone in Germany for a long time..
The relationship was so unproblematic
that we never worried
or would have to worry,
that this could be turned
against us..
Today however, we see that.
China has changed.
And that's why we have to change as well..
How much China has changed
becomes evident in mid-October at
Beijing's Silk Road Conference..
Xi Jinping marches side by side
with a man
wanted on an international
arrest warrant:
Vladimir Putin..
For Xi, Putin's brutal war of aggression against
Ukraine is no reason
to distance himself..
On the contrary..
All these external factors are
common threats
and they strengthen the
Russian-Chinese cooperation..
We have to stay outside
and like almost all western media,</b
can watch the opening ceremony only</b
on three large screens in the
press center.
For Xi, the Silk Road is
tool to expand
China's power and influence..
China promises gifts
and demands allegiance..
Xi blunbtls threatens anyone
who evades China's orders..
Those who see the development of other states as
a threat and consider
economic interdependencies
as a risk
live no better and do not further
the development of their countries..
With Putin, Xi shares a great power fantasy
which aims at incorporating other countries into their resepctive empires.
What Ukraine is for Putin, Taiwan is for Xi.
Xi's goal is the so called
return of Taiwan to the motherland.
If necessary by force..
A scenario that for many
seemed as implausible
like a war in the middle of Europe..
But ever since Russia
invaded Ukraine
a Chinese invasion of Taiwan
has become a possibility as well..
A war that that go well beyond
Indo-Pacific region.
That would drag the USA, Japan and their western allies
into it..
And that would call China's allies like
North Korea and Russia on the plan.
What we are confronted with here.
is a world war scenario.
Russia could be
seize the moment
since the Americans would then
be bound in the Pacific
and attack Europe, NATO territory,
or even
Germany..
We could
find ourselves directly involved in war..
How serious
China is about
incorporating Taiwan is evident by
its show of force:
Hundreds of fighter jets, bombers, military drones
and warships of the
People's Liberation Army
in the Strait of Taiwan.
In 2022, experts counted
1,700 Chinese flights
crossing into Taiwan's air defense zone..
This number has already been
exceeded in this year..
In military drills, China is training its troops for an invasion
of the democratically governed island
presenting its efforts on state television
to its own citizens and the world..
A demonstration of power..
We meet Victor Gao,
Vice President of the Center
for China in Globalization
and unofficial mouthpiece
of the Communist Party, for an interview.
Is there cause for concern?
that the Taiwan conflict will escalate soon?</b
China's position is very clear.
There is only one China.
Taiwan is part of China
and the Government of the People's Republic of China
is the only
legitimate representative of China.
Don't pretend,
as if you did not know this cornerstone
of the today's international order.
.
Don't pretend
that Taiwan is not a part of China..
Xi Jinping has made
the so-called reunification
his top priority..
And China has already singled out
t he culprits for a possible
military escalation:.
You are in
the USA and Taiwan..
At Taipei's
National Revolutionary Martyrs' Shrine,
people remember the victims of the civil war,
when Communist and
Republican Chinese
killed each other..
Everyone here seems worried,
that there could soon be even more killings..
Faced with constant threats
by an aggressive big brother
the small democratic
ssland state massively is massivley arming itself..
The defense budget
increases this year alone
by 14 percent to a new high..
Just now the first
Taiwan completed its first home built submarine..
The US has committed to deliver
F-16 fighter jets..
Abrams tanks have already been shipped to Taiwan..
We have an appointment at Taiwan's
Presidential Palace.
Wellington Koo, Secretary General of the National Security Council,.
has the
challenging task of
protecting his island against the
the permanent threat from China..
China seeks unification with the
Taiwanese territory
and makes no secret of it,
that it would try to achieve that in every conceivable way.
.
But the Taiwanese have a
very deep understanding,
that dictatorship and democracy
are compatible with each other..
Since the republican troops in 1949
fled from the communists to Taiwan,
China calls for the return of what it calls
the renegade island.
93 percent of
Taiwanese, however, reject this idea..
Most of them trust that
their government is doing everything necessary
to protect them..
But for some, that's not enough..
Good afternoon, I am Chuang Yuwei..
I came back from Ukraine.
six months ago..
The 52-year-old is actually a tour guide
for Japan. But in March 2022,
he decided that this time
he would travel to the Ukraine front..
We want to buy Taiwan some time.
When Ukraine falls
then maybe our
Taiwan will be hit next..
As long as we can help Ukraine
to fight another minute,
we will also have one more minute
of security for Taiwan..
This is the AK I used to
fight with in Ukraine..
In a military club in Taipei,
Chuang keeps the equipment
he received as a member of Ukraine's international
Ukraine's international legion..
The Ukrainian national flag..
If you survive
you can take it home as a souvenir. When you die
it is draped over the casket..
One soldier from Taiwan
has died in Ukraine..
After after eight months of service in Ukraine, however,
Chuang brought home with him one thing before all others:.
courage.
Before I went to the Ukraine,
I didn't know
whether we can resist the Chinese for three days, three
weeks or three months.
.
But after fighting there, I believe that if
Germany, France, Great Britain
and the United States are ready
to support Taiwan with weapons
the way they support Ukraine,
then we can beat China..
There are more souvenirs and
equipment that
Chuang brought with him..
For example, a first aid kit,
that in his view is superior to Taiwan's.
.
Chuang wants to be prepared
in case Chinese
would fight Chinese again..
In the evening he is scheduled to meet others,
who feel the same way..
In the autumn sun of
Munich, that seems a long way away off..
At Germany's IAA motor show,
Volkswagen aims to appear
as majestically as ever..
But something is different, something
seems threatening here too..
Volkswagen's electric cars
are selling poorly in China,
the world's most important car market..
The former top brand in China
is currently being dethroned
by brands from China..
One of them, BYD, has set up
built directly opposite.
It looks like a duel
on Munich's grand boulevard..
For Volkswagen, everything is at stake here..
No other company in Germany
is so dependent on business in China..
The fact that Chinese e-cars
are threatening to pull away,
is life-threatening for Volkswagen..
For China's carmakers,
on the other hand, it is a source of satisfaction./b>.
We offer
probably something a bit different
to German car makers..
In China, digital functionality
in the car is very important..
I don't think they believed
in electromobility at all..
Volkswagen or GM,
they were dominating..
But what we see today is that
Chinese car manufacturers
have over 60% market share in electromobility..
Pieter Nota, at that time
BMW Board Member for Customer, Brands, and Sales,
inspects China's e-cars..
The arrogance of German car managers
towards Chinese models was legendary.
.
Today, car bosses flock in droves
to study the Chinese.
And their own failings.
.
Including Wolfgang Porsche,
the powerful VW owner.
And in tow:
VW boss Oliver Blume..
We are still in China the
strongest automotive company..
It is crucial for us now,</b
that we suceed in the transformation
to electromobility..
The Chinese say
German cars are uncool
I'd rather buy a BYD then.
So then maybe VW will get, I don't know,
only 20 or 30 percent of its profits from China..
That would be a disaster for Wolfsburg, of course..
In the large exhibition hall in Munich,
an alarmed
Germany-AG takes up its positions..
Chancellor next to car bosses..
Scholz rushes to Munich,
rushes to the aid Volkswagen and co.
The attack from
China causes something to slip..
Profits of German brands.
And with them hundreds of thousands
of jobs in Germany..
The mobility turnaround
is a major task.
But it's a team effort..
I'm here to see you today
as a convinced member of this team..
The team is fighting against
a major opponent..
China's e-cars are cheap
because Beijing apparently
subsidizes them unfairly..
Germany could could fight back
with Europe-wide punitive tariffs..
This is the
idea of our China strategy,.
to create a level playing and to say:
You protect your markets,
you make subsidies,
we then protect our markets,
from your products. We demand
equal rights for all..
We will not be
pushed out of the playing field..
Not to use this toolbox
at a time
when we can see that the volume
and price of electric cars pushing into our markets.
is something that will cause</b
a structural shift in these markets,
that would be madness.</b
.
But will Germany dare?
Will Europe dare
to engage in a tough conflict with China?</b
Suddenly something else happens..
The party is over,
announces Greenpeace.
Bodyguards shield Scholz.
It's about climate change. But what if
a completely different party comes to an end here as well?
An entire industry?
Germany's economic model?.
Trade with China,
has long been a party..
Angela Merkel called
Beijing a "strategic partner"..
The principle: Germany supplies
engineering, China cheap goods.
We thought that in an authoritarian state
there are not the possibilities
to freedom and creativity as there
are in democracy.
That's why we can actually easily
trade with China,
because China will always
try to copy
what we export there, but they
will always be one
one step behind us..
Because the Chinese are industrious, but
They obey, they have no ideas..
That was the cliché?.
Exactly..
It was a terrible mistake, because that
led to
China catching up and in some
cases overtaking us./b>cases.
For Germany's economic bosses,
trade with China was a
highly profitable gift..
Now it is becoming a a danger, because China
has caught up, in some
areas overtaken.areas.
We have reached a point where
you notice that
the balance is shifting.
Imports from China are increasing, our
exports to China are on the decline..
The economic balance
ia shifting towards China..
And this is the moment when, from a German
perspective, we have to pause
and say:
Do we really want it this way?
The German
business model is finished.
And from your point of view, what is that based on?
Well, it is basedon the fact
tht we import cheap primary products from China,</b
cheap gas from Russia, do business
all over the world
and the Americans are
paying for our security..
So, that's definitely over now..
Corona and Russia`s war against Ukraine
have shown us, how dependent we are</b
global supply chains.
.
But our dependence on China is
actually even greater.
Responsible for Germany's trade is the
Federal Minister of Economics..
What lessons has Robert Habeck learned?
We had 55% gas dependency and we
just about made it
to keep the national economy running.
90 would not have been possible..
We were able to.
replace 55% with high
inflation, with high prices,</b
and a deep
economic crisis,</b
with a period of weakness that
lasted the whole year..
90% would have pulled our feet from under us..
90% that's how
dependendant we are from China, for
some
medicines or rare earths..
If there is a
confrontation with Taiwan
then the relationships between
Germany and China
will change completely overnight..
A war of aggression would
result in sanctions against China..
And the
world's most important trade route would disrupted.
Direct trade with China alone
would probably cost us
1 million jobs,
if we had to cut ties overnight.
.
But that's not all..
Through the Taiwan Strait
between a third to
one half of the global trade in goods
is being shipped.
None of that
would arrive..
That means we would have supply bottlenecks
and we would have mass unemployment..
Nobody really wants to imagine that..
The federal government has now issued a
China strategy..
The goal is called de-risking..
Less China risk,
less China naivety..
But what does that mean?
How could it work?
Taiwan thought early on about how
it can hedge its bets..
His ace is the semiconductor industry..
One of the most valuable companies in the
world, TSMC, is located in Taiwan..
If Taiwan's foreign trade were interrupted,</b
then that would be a major disaster.
not just for Taiwan,
but for the whole world..
Because Taiwan represents 60 percent of the
worldwide production of semiconductors..
TSMC, the Taiwan Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company,
has dedicated a museum to semiconductors,
its successful product..
The tiny chips are in
Refrigerators, cars and
mobile phones all over the world..
The success of an industrial policy that
has beend pursued for decades..
In the past, TSMC, like
everyone else, focused om costs
and invested heavily in China..
But they started earlier than we did
to rethink and focus on de-risking..
The mainland has increasingly
emerged as our competitor..
As a result, Taiwan's
investments in mainland China
in the last 14 years
has gone down gradually./b>.
In 2020, even the last
Taiwanese companies have understood
that production costs are no longer the
most important factor
for a company's business
but that they need to take geopolitical considerations
and risk diversification
into account..
The TSMC museum commemorates the Seven
Fathers of Taiwan's electrical industry.
Managers and government officials who
almost 50 years ago
sat down in
a soy milk snack shack
and made a
far-ranging decision..
Kristi Xu is an
economist..
She knows TSMC inside out..
She takes us to a soy milk bar, where we choose between
soy milk, warm or
cold, sweet or salty..
proteins that the founding fathers of the
Taiwanese
electrical industry.
might have consumed as well.
They decided that we should
concentrate our expertise on one product.
And that we should develop something
that could not simply be copied
by our neighboring countries..
The plan received government
support and was a complete sucess..
Today, the whole world depends
on Taiwan's semiconductors..
The production process is
uniquely sophisticated..
It's very ironic, but even if
the Chinese were to conquer TSMC,
they would only get the factory, the building. Because the people have legs and most of the engineers have a green card.
They can just go to the USA. What TSMC is at its core would no
longer work.
Neither China nor the rest of
the world can afford it
if the supply of semicunductors fails.
.
So China will think twice before really attacking Taiwan
And the international
Community will try everything
to prevent a war over Taiwan..
And not only that.
Taiwan's strategy has far-reaching
implications on global trade
and onEurope, says Mathieu Duchâtel,
one of the leading Taiwan experts..
I think that is
practiced de-risking,
i.e. risk minimization by Taiwan..
That does not mean that
globalization is completely dead..
I think we are dealing with
a certain degree of de-globalization,.
but we remain in the world of
inter-dependencies,
of linking supply chains.
That remains..
But there are more
and more exeptions to this rule..
Taiwan has a silicon shield,
.
a protective shield
made of semiconductors..
And Germany?
It is precisely this
protective shield against China that it is missing..
There is no protective shield
for the medicines that Anton urgently needs.
No alternative to
the missing antibiotics..
The treatment for Anton is not working..
With a severe pneumonia,
Anton's parents have to take him
to hospital..
His oxygen levels were very low..
Anton was actually in a very bad condition..
He had trouble
breathing, trouble walking..
He didn't feel like doing anything because he
simply lacked all strength..
If you don't get antibiotics
it's just bad..
It is very painful as a parent,
because you can't help your child.
Because there is nothing there to help with..
Yet antibiotics were produced in Germany for decades.
.
Penicillin was produced in
Frankfurt-Höchst from 1950 onwards.
So much that after just a few years
tall of Germany
could be supplied..
This medicine will save the lives of countless Germans
in the years to come.
It is very difficult to imagine..
If you think about how much penicillin
and cephalosporins
were manufactured at Höchst.
after the Second World War and
into this millennium..
And at some point
the Chinese thought
we don't like that.
We want the
market to be dependent on us..
And they flooded the market with dumping prices
for their starting materials..
That means: The Chinese have made sure that.
due to dumping prices the production
at Höchst had to close down? Yes.
The Höchst building is now an industrial monument..
Since 2017
there is no more any antibiotics production.
Because everyone was only looking
at the price..
With hindsight,</b
you can certainly say it was a strategic mistake, but
at the same time it was simply cheaper
to produce in China..
You have to
ask our insurance companies,
are you willing to pay
Dmore for medication
because we have produced it in Europe or in India
or in America?
In essence, the price pressure from insurance companies</b
and consumers has led to
all these difficult
product categories
migrating to China..
Just how dependent
Germany has become on China,
became clear the year before at the latest..
In October 2016, a boiler explodes in an
antibiotics factory in eastern China.
We heard a loud bang
and we all ran outside..
When I came out, the
street was full of people..
We saw flames several meters high..
The company Qilu produces the antibiotic
piperacillin here..
In Germany, there is an immediate
supply shortage
for products containing piperacillin..
Thanks to its dumping prices, China has mangaged to make sure
that certain antibiotics are now only produced
in China..
Cephalosporins, for example, are now only produced in
three large factories..
We write to the companies.
Almost always they answer: No interview!
Or we are suspected of espionage
A popular formulation to avoid annoying
questions from journalists.
Foreigners are infiltrating China badly.
The whole country is fighting
spies now..
They can't talk about political topics.
Too sensitive..
At Qilu, China's
large antibiotics company,
the press office sounds like this:
We have no interest in
working with foreign media..
We do not do any external communication
via foreign media. Goodbye!
We travel to one of the
cephalosporine plants
in Shanxi province..
Qilu's exports to
Europe last year increased
by 130 %..
At the main entrance of the
antibiotics factory one employee,
agress to
talk to us..
We produce cephalosporins..
Our products go all over the world..
I'm really proud of that!.
Our presence has
not gone unnoticed..
Discussion with
security staff at the main entrance..
Filming prohibited..
China tries to make others dependent on itself.
And China autonomous..
De-risking with Chinese characteristics even
has its own name:.
The system of dual circulation..
It means: To prepare itself for trade war,
China wants to boost domestic consumption
and reduce its dependence
from exports..
Isn't de-risking exactly what
China for many
years has been practicing itself?
In other words, making itself more independent.
Isolating itself from foreign influences?
Isn't that the same strategy?
No, I don't think so..
Since 1978,
China has opened up to the world
and reformed its politics and economy..
China sees itself as
indispensable part of the world..
It wanted to embrace the world..
But if a country
wants to exert maximum pressure on China,</b
if it wants to de-couple,
if it wants to deny China access to
high technologies,
then China must do the right thing..
So invest heavily to mobilize all talents,.
it must to become self-reliant..
That is not what China wanted in the beginning.
That's what the wrong policies of other countries
have forced us to do..
China has no other choice.
German corporations
on the other hand, risk even more..
Their China investments
have risen significantly..
I believe that there are still some in the economy who say that we are simply looking
to make optimal profits with China..
But that they are not also
minimizing risks..
For fear of being left behind,
Volkswagen invests 2.5 billion euros in
a project with Horizon Robotics..
The Chinese are the leaders in
self-driving cars..
We want to give the customer the
the best there is..
And then we just take the best
solutions available in the regions..
It's an expensive bet on the future..
On the fact that profit in China
works like a VW Beetle used to:.
It runs and runs and runs..
It could be a fallacy.
We will have to
replace the Chinese market,</b
because, in the long term, our
companies will no longer play
the role
they have played in the last 10,
20 years..
But in the wake of the big players,
the smaller ones are carrying on as before as well..
Supplier companies like the
Neue Zahnradwerk Leipzig GmbH
with a about 1000 employees..
Hubertus Bartsch built up the company
over 20 years ago..
Eight years ago,
a factory in China was added.
Volkswagen's sales problems in China
are also affecting him..
The best times are when my brain is not
working at night.
But you can believe me,
that I have relatively rarely slept in recent years..
Also this year..
His company traditionally produces motor-
and transmission parts
for combustion engines..
But now e-cars are
important, especially in China..
And the question is:
Can Bartsch manage the transition?
And what will happen to
his most important customer?
To Volkswagen?
Will the Group
continue to order more from Bartsch,
even if things get tight for VW itself?
SMEs in particular
in the automotive supply chain
are currently under extreme pressure..
Moving away from the combustion engine to the electric car..
And some will certainly
fall through the cracks..
At the moment, Bartsch has the feeling</b
that he has got away with it once again..
During the pandemic, he only saw his Chinese
colleagues on the screen..
Now, for the first time, he returns
once again to Tianjin..
He is nervous..
.
What will await him there?
In 2015, we have accompanied
Bartsch once before..
The China factory, built for around 50 million
Euro, was brand new at the time..
From Bartsch' shirt pocket
his passport was visible..
He was constantly commuting between two worlds..
It was the time of the China euphoria..
We belong to a few private investors..
This is not just a matter of the heart,
it is also a part of our existence..
That means you need to suceed in China?
Yes, we will suceed..
Bartsch has been producing here for
eight years now..
No passport is peeking out of his shirt anymore..
It seems like China is farther away today
than back then..
If only because of Corona..
It was a long and exhausting time..
I am very surprised,
that we are in such
good shape at the moment..
That the employees, the whole team
over the years
have kept this business running alone..
The pandemic could be a
warning about dependencies..
What it's like to suddenly
be cut off from supply chains.
and your own multi-million investments..
My assessment is that German companies,</b
who operate in China must know that their investments there
maybe treated completely
different
than in constitutional states like in Europe..
That they could be expropriated?
Well, that is is certainly not
only a theoretical possibility..
Bartsch, however, does not want to minimize risks</b
de-risk..
There is also de-industrialization..
Everything that starts with "D" goes downhill..
We are very strongly organized in China.
But the bottom line
for our company
is that we
have to make sure
that our risk in China.
reimains acceptable.
They are working on this all over Taiwan.
The head of the GEOSAT company
focuses on deterrence and armor. Lo Chen-Fang produces civilian
and also increasingly military drones,
because Taiwan is upgrading.
It has to, says the flight engineer.
Fujian in South China,
where the Chinese have
deployed their missiles,
is only two hours away by plane.
Since the visit of the Speaker of the US House of Representatives
Pelosi last year
China's missile positions
have moved to the front.
So far, they have only been able
to reach the eastern part of Taiwan.
But now their range
covers every square centimeter
of Taiwan's territory.
To test their machines
in battle,
there has been.
a sad test field.
since February 2022.
The Ukraine.
One of GEOSAT's helicopter drones
is to be be sent there soon.
Li Chengling will accompany it.
The drones can fly normally
and take photos at the same time.
You can take pictures
of a huge area
and return automatically.
Or you can set a route so that it stops at certain locations
to drop something to eat or drink, some fuel or supplies.
The drone can
also drop other things, of course.
Li Chengling knows what is
needed at the Ukrainian front.
Because he has already been there.
Just after
the outbreak of war, he quit his job
as an Uber driver
and drove off.
The former
French foreign legionnaire
wanted to experience something again.
The irony of globalization:
The Taiwanese Li flew Chinese drones
on the Ukrainian front.
And on his return he was
immediately hired by GEOSAT.
Now he will bring
a donation to Ukraine.
There are many young people in Taiwan,</b
who went to Ukraine as international volunteers.
That was very brave.
The long-term
development, however, is important.
In other words, what can we learn
from the Ukrainian battlefield?</b
As far as the use of drones is concerned,</b
it is a modern and
necessary instrument
on the battlefield, if it is
successvully integrated
into the existing
troop units.
We have to study this new
technique of warfare
and also introduce it in Taiwan.
Charity paired
with sober calculation
is supposed to aid the small
Asian democracy
to oppose their
totalitarian neighbor.
In order to minimize the risk
of an attack.
China aims at minimizing
its own risk.
China sees itself in a
global competition with the USA.
At the center of Beijing's strategy: dominance in certain
particularly valuable raw materials.
Yunnan Province, Southwest China.
Our goal is a mine
of the company Yunnan Chihong.
It delivers nearly a third of the
worldwide production of Germanium.
The company video is filled
with success stories.
Germanium and Gallium
are extremely important metals
for the production of semiconductors.
Germany can be blackmailed
because it has also made itself dependent
on rare metals.
More than half of its
Galliums stems from China.
The figure for Germanium is 82%.
Since August, China has
restricted their export.
It's retribution for
US trade sanctions,
but it also affects Germany.
In August, exports of
Germanium and Gallium from China dropped to zero.
China could at any time for some products
turn off the tap and then say
then you don't get any
Germanium or Gallium.
So far, it was just an announcement that
certificates were needed.
This was not a ban.
You have to learn from that, you have to
see what could happen.
The tunnels of the mine of Yunnan
go up to 2 km deep.
To our interview request
Chihong did not respond.
At the main entrance barbed wire
and a warning sign.
"Strict ban on access for strange
people and vehicles!"
A security guard immediately confronts us.
We ask again for an interview.
I'll have to ask the head office, they
decide whether you can get in.
You are not allowed in now.
The mood is tense.
The security guard is visibly uncomfortable
with our sudden appearance.
The company doesn't want to talk to us.
Rejections from government agencies, too.
Only Victor Gao,
Vice President of the "Center for China
and Globalization" and
unofficial mouthpiece
of the Communist Party,
agrees to do an interview.
China has absolute dominance in
rare earths and metals.
China still has two dozen aces up its sleeve.
We have no problem with Germany.
But if the Federal Republic of Germany were to follow the USA
with their unjustified sanctions
against China,
then exports to
Germany will just be as regulated,
like the Chinese government is already doing this
as far as the rare metals Gallium
and Germanium are concerned.
As with antibiotics, Germany also had
a Gallium production of its owny.
Here in Stade, near Hamburg.
But only until 2017.
Gallium from Stade was
not competitive.
Then there is the political question,</b
is the production of Gallium
in Germany worth the effort?
Regarding security of supply,
regarding competitiveness.
For the semiconductor industry
this question seems to be answered.
2, 1, to the future!
In May 2023
the EU
Commission President and Chancellor
digitally break the ground
at Infineon in Dresden
for a new semiconductor factory.
Semiconductors are often referred to as the oil of the
21st century,
The one raw material, so to speak, on which
almost everything else depends.
By 2030 we want,
together with our industries,.
to double Europe's share of the
worldwide semiconductor production
to 20 percent.
And because the semiconductor market
is developing so rapidly,
it actually means for us?
that our current capacities
need to quadruple.
43 billion Euros
the EU provides for this.
Under these conditions
Dresden is also
attractive for TSMC.
A fool who thinks
that Taiwan's
most important company
can do as it pleases
when investments like these are concerned.
Earlier TSMC invested a lot in China.
Not anymore.
Because the semiconductor industry
is part of the national
security strategy.
We think a lot about
the economic security of semiconductor design.
We respect the global
position of the company.
But it must be guaranteed
that Taiwan's lead in this
industry remains intact.
That is, the
most modern production processes
and the research
must stay in Taiwan.
The latest investments by TSMC
all went to closely allied countries.
A coincidence? No, it's not a coincidence.
That means we agree
to the development
of a global network.
But to protect the supply chains, TSMC
only goes to countries with similar values.
Industrial policy, there and here.
On this green meadow in Dresden
in about four years, TSMC will
produce semiconductors.
Not the most modern, which production is to remain in Taiwan.
But previous generations,
which are needed by the European
automotive industry.
The Taiwanese want
to invest 10 billion Euros.
About half of it they will
get subsidized.
Is this
money well spent for Germany?
In my view
you are partly lying
to yourself a bit.
The impact on the global industry
will not fundamentally change over the next ten years
with the measures we
currently have in Europe.
If by 2030 we only have six additional
factories in Europe,</b
it won't be enough
to reach the 20% promised by
von der Leyen.
Because at the same time
new factories are also created in China, Taiwan,</b
Korea, Japan and
in the USA.
We should therefore
forget the 20 percent
and see that
our production becomes more European.
A criticism that the responsible
Federal Minister of Economics
does not like to accepted as such.
First of all, you have to start at some point.
as semiconductors will be everywhere soon.
We are well advised
to produce at least a part
of what we consume by ourselves.
Sometimes I don't understand it either.
There are major concerns
about the attractiveness of the
industry location of Germany.
Then some companies
come and build or want to build
the leading industry
over the next few decades
and then this is also criticized.
Germany tries to do at least something
in order to become more autonomous.
But Chinese high-tech has long been
at the center of our communication,</b
operating the German mobile networks,
critical infrastructure.
How much conflict does Berlin dare to have
in order to reduce this risk?
This is perhaps also a logical
error of our
de-risking discussion right now.
Because it has the appearance of something
completely peaceful.
We just need to de-risk a bit.
Minimize the risk a little,
Diversify a little.
As if the
Chinese leadership would not realize.
As if she hadn't
quite an interest</b
that the opposite happens.
Because China doesn't want
to be de-risked.
We really have to
think through, where are we dependent
where can we find other partners
to have some alternatives.
But not in order to say we'll buy
nothing from China anymore,
but to tell the Chinese, you
can't blackmail us.
The skyline of the high-tech metropolis
Shenzhen is in sight,
if you are on board the Huawei Line 1, driving
through a retort Europe,
which the founder of the company
had built as a company campus.
From one stop to the next
strolling from Paris
via Bologna and Oxford,
to Rome or Heidelberg.
Rarely do
western media get insights here.
We have been invited
to an exclusive tour.
Here we are now in Heidelberg and this
is a driverless car, especially for you.
Autonomous and futuristic we drive through
the copy of
Heidelberg's romantic alleyways,
over bridges, past
rivers and small lakes.
A fairyland, so it seems,
which is highly symbolic.
They are be the symbol of
China's resiliance.
Black Swans.
According to superstition and also in Huawei's
company history, they stand for
an unforeseeable event,
that can have serious consequences.
Huawei says misfortune and threat have
made them even stronger.
That's why the black swans are
fed and cared for with great love
on the company campus.
The animals are supposed to
remind the staff every day
to always be
prepared for the unforeseeable.
Charm offensive with
a private tour, lunch and Carsten Senz.
He is Huawei's spokesman for Germany,</b
actually works in Düsseldorf.
The only reason why Huawei
exist is to serve our customers.
I know, it always sounds a bit
like a
marketing slogan, but it isnt't.
Huawei's self-promotion offensive
aims at the Federal Government.
Because another
black swan is in the room.
Berlin sees in Huawei's
5G technology a security risk
and fears China could
install malware
and spy upon Germany via
remote maintenance.
Perhaps even switch off networks and
critical infrastructure.
Huawei denies this.
We as the supplier have no access,
no remote access to data
in mobile networks or on the control
of mobile networks.
These nets are under the
control of the network operators.
These scenarios of espionage and
sabotage belong in the
realm of Science Fiction.
But the science fiction, so the
fear, could become reality.
Because China's
national security law,
obligates companies to provide information
for the Party and the state.
In the USA are
Huawei components have therefore long been taboo.
</b
.
When the German government is determined
to shoot its own knee, be my guest.
We can't stop you.
We can't stop people from
doing all the stupid things
which will inflict all the damage,</b
injuries and losses to the German people.
But I personally hope
that the German government,
as I have always perceived them,
will be smarter and wiser.
A ban of Chinese 5G technology
for German network operators,
it would have a signal effect for the whole of Europe.
We don't want to lose any country
as a customer
especially not the biggest market
in Europe, the German market.
If you can survive an thrive
on the German market,
you can also do that
in many other markets.
The German telephone providers are also running
up in arms about possible restrictions.
They threaten Berlin with claims for damages.
Despite all the safety concerns.
Like the car companies, they want to carry on
with China as before.
The pressure on politicians is enormous.
I myself have
always made very clear
that risk minimization also includes</b
that we have no technology from China here
in our infrastructure,
with which we are vulnerable.
And I think we have to
be self-confident enough
and say we won't let
anyone put us under pressure.
Obviously after all.
Germany tries a compromise
De-risking light, so to speak.
For now, only be a small but
significant part of the
Huawei technology is banned
and more transparency demanded from China.
But even on our hour-long
visit to the Huawei's Europe
we have only seen the facades of.
China's megatech firm.
In Taiwan, people are happy about anything that
hints a growing distance to China.
It gives them hope that Germany would,
in the event of a conflict,
consistently be on the side of the
democratic Taiwan.
We would like to see
that Germany is ready
to use their warships
in the Asia-Pacific region
and to hold military drills
in the Indo-Pacific region .
But who knows if the international
help is coming after all?
For peace in the Taiwan Strait
it is very important
that the Taiwanese political leadership
convince Beijing
that they can
withstand an attack.
Because if the impression arises that the
Taiwanese society
will capitulate very quickly,
the probability of an attack
increases very strongly.
They don't trust in this.
They meet once a week with
military discipline
at the open-air stage
of Da'an Park in Taipei.
What we hope is that we will
be able to demonstrate our
determination to fight back.
We cannot expect from other countries
to help us,
if we do not show the will
to do so.
So they, decidedly and somewhat touching,
practice close combat.
They forgot the
wooden rifles today.
But that doesn't stop their enthusiasm.
Self-defense groups like this one now
exist all over the country.
The young Taiwanese in particular feel
no ties to the People's Republic
and want to be
prepared for the worst case scenario.
Once the catastrophe is here,</b
we will all be nervous
and perhaps forget
what we already knew before.
But through constant practicing the
movement becomes a muscle memory
and then we can
make decisions
which might rescue our own lives
and perhaps even that of
our family members.
Today Chuang Yuwei is their star guest.
The man who fought in Ukraine
last year
is now bravely taking part in weight training.
But actually he came,
to demonstrate his Ukrainian
first aid set.
Yes, that's a bandage.
Yes, yes, if you have one hole
in the front and one in the back.
His listeners are spellbound.
What they train for appears much closer
through his words.
He really went to Ukraine
and returned alive.
That's very admirable.
I have seen the things he brought
along today before.
But today I have
got it for the first time,
that they were really
used in a war.
At the end of a long training evening
the hero is emotionally agitated.
What he sings is the anthem of Ukraine.
Whether China is really going to
attack Taiwan, we don't know.
But Taiwan tries
to prepare for it.
And Germany?
What we need to do in Germany
is to become more independent
and that we also position us self-confidently
against China.
And I think that helps in the end, too.
for a better
relationship with China.
To be less dependent, less vulnerable
is going to be expensive.
We have to be able to provide
the basic care
for our population.
We certainly also have
to diversify widely,
that we do not have to accept such
country risks politically.
But Germany is not
at China's mercy.
China needs Europe, too.
We are dependent on some products.
But China also needs the European market.
And China also needs
imports from Europe.
In Berlin, Anton and his
father are at the doctor's once again.
The therapy in the
hospital has helped Anton.
His lungs are healthy again.
I'm so glad this
did not end a different way.
I'm very happy that it didn't turn out differently. But you don't want to
get into a situation like this again.
Then you get frustrated
and angry.
That it even comes to this.
Do you still remember
what it was like for you
to go to the hospital?
Yes, even once during the night.
Then I actually did not want
to go to the hospital.
How are you today?
Good.
For Anton, things went
off without a hitch.
Malik Böttcher now collects
medications which are
not quite used up and which
his patients gave to him.
Perhaps he has
something in the drawer,
when things get tight again.
This is
born out of necessity.
Theoretically, we are not allowed to do that.
But we just do it anyway.
Because there are currently many situations where patients
cannot start their therapy on the day.
Because they have to wait 2-3 days until the
medication is available.
You often notice your own blackmailability
only when things
happen, as with Anton.
When a confusing,
disturbing world intervenes,
in the life of a six-year-old.
But dependence is
nothing fated.
It is made.
And that's why it can
be reduced again.
If you want to.